[Applaudissements]
ça va vous êtes bien une petite question
pour vous est ce que vous savez qui est
assis à côté de vous
je vous parle pas des personnes que vous
connaissez pas que vous connaissez et de
ce que vous ne connaissez pas les
inconnus qui sont là tout proche de vous
pouvez vous pour un instant prendre le
temps de vous regarder allez-y
les organisateurs m'ont dit que j'avais
tout mon temps je regarde même pas le
chrono ça va ça vient
cette connaissance n'ayez pas peur c'est
dingue comme on a peur d'aller vers les
autres
je vais vous aider un peu imaginez que
votre vie dépendent de cette personne
imaginez que la vie de cette personne de
sa famille de ses enfants dépendent de
vous là c'est plus compliqué je vais
vous expliquer où je veux en venir
depuis 25 ans je parcours le monde à la
rencontre de peuples extraordinaire
certains les appellent les peuples
autochtones ou les peuples premiers
moi je préfère les appeler les
flamboyants tant qu'ils sont
éblouissants par leur courage et par
leur humilité éparpillés partout dans le
monde
ces hommes ces femmes ces enfants sont
fiers de leur culture et de leurs
traditions
ce sont les gardiens de leur terre une
terre qu'il revendique comme faisant
partie de même aujourd'hui ils sont face
à notre expansion à notre progrès
nous qui sommes bien au chaud
emmitouflées dans notre confort avons
nous conscience de ce qu'il représente
mesurons nous seulement ce qu'ils vivent
sommes nous à l écoute de ce qu'ils
demandent si nous n'apprenons pas à les
connaître
nous n'entendrons pas leurs messages et
leurs messages nous concerne tous la
première fois que j'ai rencontré l'un de
ces peuples flamboyant c'était en russie
dans l'oural polaire
ce jour là je rencontrais andrei yvan
piotte et anna des nomades nenets je
n'imaginais pas à quel point ils
allaient transformer ma vie
les nenets vous avez déjà entendu parler
des nénettes les nenets sont les maîtres
de l'arctique
les seigneurs de la toundra ce sont les
plus grands éleveurs de rennes au monde
chaque jour ils sont dehors pour trouver
des pâturages pour nourrir leurs bêtes
en hiver il fait moins 50 degrés en été
la toundra se transforme en un immense
marécage leur vie est dure extrêmement
dure toute la nature qui les entoure est
sacré même planté un couteau dans le sol
peut-être une offense pour les esprits
qui les entoure cette rencontre m'a
tellement impressionné que pendant 15
ans je suis retourné à leur rencontre à
tout les sens saison et a tout dans tous
les environnements possible à chaque
fois ils montent accueillis et aidés
avec une gentillesse extraordinaire
façon de voir à de la vie leur capacité
d'adaptation leur savoir-faire m'ont
complètement fasciné et me fascine
encore aujourd'hui avec le temps j'ai
voyagé j'ai rencontré des dizaines
d'autres communautés éparpillés à
travers le monde à chaque fois j'ai
retrouvé une partie des enseignements de
mes amis nenets mais j'ai aussi
découvert une multitude de richesse
extraordinaire
j'aimerais j'aimerais que ces peuples
soit avec nous j'aimerais vous emmener à
leur rencontre
j'aimerais qu'il soit là pour partager
ce moment qu'il voit vos regards
imaginez que par magie on puisse survolé
la planète en un instant nous sommes
chez les mentawai au lever du jour
nous partons dans la forêt cueillir des
fleurs les mentawai m décorées leurs
cheveux chaque jour ils mettent un point
d'honneur à être beau pour honorer les
esprits de la nature qui les entoure le
soir avec les chamans nous parlons des
arbres qui les nourrissent oui les
mentawai mange des arbres à chaque fois
qu'ils en plantes qu'ils en coupe 1 il
en replante un autre chez les mentawai
on nous prend rien dans la nature sans
penser aux générations futures
c'est une règle c'est la loi
en fermant les yeux nous sommes en
bolivie sur les hauts plateaux des andes
nous marchons sur les plus grandes
étendues salée du monde les salars des
déserts presque invivable c'est dans cet
environnement hostile que les chicayas
ont trouvé refuge
avant de rentrer chez eux
vous êtes accueillis par le comité du
village cet ensemble que les villageois
décident ou pas de vous accepter sur
leurs terres avec leur accord
nous allons construire de petits
barrages pour guider lot de la seule
rivière qui coule dans la région pour
survivre les chipaya lave la terre pour
en éliminer le sel qui la rend impropre
à l'agriculture
chez les chicayas l'individu n'est rien
parce qu'il ne peut pas survivre
le groupe représente la vie en un
claquement de doigts nous sommes en
mongolie chez une famille d'éleveurs
nous sommes accueillis avec une ex pete
alité extraordinaire pour partager une
transhumance blotti sur le dos d'un
chameau bactriane nous avançons sur les
dunes du désert de gobi soir nous
arrivons au nouveau campement et les
anciens nous explique le sens de cette
journée
méticuleusement choisis en fonction de
la position des astres et de la lune
ce déplacement est un rituel qui rend
hommage à la nature qui leur donne la
vie chez les mongols le sacré est
partout les simples il est accessible à
tous il fait partie de la vie toutes les
populations que j'ai rencontrés sont
différentes mais elles ont tous un point
commun elles sont tous une source
d'inspiration et d'enseignement pour
nous
elle nous propose d'autres façons de
penser de voir où d'entendre
elle nous propose d'autres façons
d'appréhender la vie
ce sont de véritables trésors pour
l'humanité leurs connaissances leur
savoir-faire nous propose d'autres
façons d'appréhender le corps et
l'esprit
laure relation aux autres leur
solidarité nous renvoie des valeurs que
nous avons perdu leur capacité
d'adaptation leur résistance sont autant
de pistes d'exploration face à notre
avenir parfois incertains ce sont eux
les champions de la résilience dans un
monde où l'uniformisation des cultures
et généralisée il nous propose le
foisonnement la diversité ils nous
proposent le choix avoir le choix
c'est être libre une liberté que nous
finirons par perdre si nous ne faisons
pas d'arguments prenons pas garde de
préserver toutes ses différences vous
trouvez ça intéressant que l'on
s'habille tous pareils ce que l'on mange
tous la même chose et que l'on parle
tous la même langue
aujourd'hui toutes ces populations sont
confrontées à notre expansion ces dix
dernières années j'ai vu leurs
territoires les plus secrets être
menacée par l'exploitation du gaz du
pétrole de l'or j'ai vu leur jardin les
plus sucrés être attaqué par la
déforestation
partout dans le monde on veut les
déplacés les relocaliser pour mieux les
asservir mieux les contrôler leur voix
s'élèvent de plus en plus forte
mais les entendons nous certains de ces
peuples préfère rester isolé traumatisé
par des violences passées d'autres sont
carrément assassiné coupable du simple
fait d'exister
c'est à ce moment que notre
développement se fait prédateurs et que
le progrès devient un danger pour eux
c'est aussi à ce moment que notre regard
se trouble
si nous les plaçons sur un piédestal
nous finissons par oublier les
l'humanité qu'il représente autre figure
du patrimoine un peu comme des pièces de
musée qui vivrait à une autre époque
si nous les considérons comme des
résistants nous avons l'impression
qu'ils sont opposés à tout développement
à toute évolution
ça va vous sembler paradoxal mais c'est
exactement l'opposé toutes les
populations que j'ai rencontré souhaite
s'ouvrir vers l'extérieur
elles veulent prendre le meilleur des
deux mondes
elles veulent plus de confort plus de
santé plus d'éducation pour leurs
enfants elles veulent avoir plus de paix
et plus de sécurité pour leur communauté
elle vole d'avoir plus de commerce plus
des chances avec l'extérieur mais avec
le monde
pas facile de vous parler de ça parce
que beaucoup de gens considèrent leur
vie comme paradisiaque avec le temps mon
regard mais voyez h et les nenets mon
regard a changé
peu à peu j'ai vu mes amis mourir
emporté par le froid les accidents les
maladies les noyades
je les ai vu souffrir de leur isolement
de la rudesse de leur quotidien
j'ai vu leur détresse devant leurs
enfants leurs familles leurs proches qui
disparaissait je les ai entendu appeler
de l'aide
savez vous ce que cela veut dire de
vivre en condition d'isolement c'est 20
à 25 ans d'espérance de vie en moins que
nous c'est une mortalité infantile qui
s'élèvent parfois à deux enfants sur 5
ce sont des conditions de vie tellement
rude pour les femmes pour les enfants
c'est d accès aux soins à l'éducation au
travail au commerce
inexistant
et une chose dont on parle peu leurs
traditions sont parfois violentes et
cruelles et ses traditions n'ont plus
lieu d'exister aujourd'hui c'est moi
vous donner trois exemples il ya
quelques temps je revenais voir mon ami
ndahi chez les korowai chez eux les
guerres ont fait les guerres les
violences les enlèvements fait tellement
de morts y a que peu de temps qu'ils ont
décidé de baisser les armes
c'était impossible de les imaginer se
déplacer en forêt sans leurs marques et
leurs flèches à la main il ne pouvait
même pas laisser leurs femmes seules de
peur qu'elle soit enlevé vous pouvez
imaginer le changement et le quotidien
qu'ils vivent qu'ils ont vécu
chaque jour l'angoissent la peur de
vivre sous la tacc devoir perdre un
frère un père
il ya quelques temps je retournais en
mongolie voir mon ami ou georges
à mon arrivée il me dit qu'est ce que tu
penses de la nouvelle cabane que je
viens de construire moi je vous dis les
super il me dit tu vois quand les
touristes viennent nous voir il me
demande pourquoi nous ne passons plus
l'hiver dans nos tentes de toile non
oates je le redis l'hiver nos enfants
ont froid nous avons froid il fait moins
les tentes la toile détente coûte cher
ils me répondent que nous perdons nos
traditions que nous allons disparaître
je leur dis mais ce n'est pas parce que
nous changeons d'habitat que nous allons
disparaître être fatal c'est le sang qui
coule dans mes veines
il ya quelques temps je revenais en inde
au zanskar retrouver dolma sur le chemin
qui mène au monastère de phuktal j'étais
surpris de voir le chantier de
construction d'une route
les ouvriers faisait exploser la
montagne à coude dynamique pour faire
avancer leurs rouleaux de goudron à mon
arrivée chez dolma je me faisais part de
mes inquiétudes
j'ai demandé ce qu'elle pensait elle me
dit tu vois franck c'est la meilleure
chose qui pouvait nous arriver
nos enfants pourront aller à l'école les
malades pourront être évacués les
touristes pourront venir nous visiter et
avec un petit air malicieux elle rajoute
un et vous vous faites comment chez vous
vous n'avez pas de route au lieu de voir
nos différences nous ferions mieux de
voir nos similitudes nos points communs
nous devrons nous devons essayer de
comprendre leur fragilité et d'entendre
leurs messages leur message est un
message d'unité
il nous demande d'aller les uns vers les
autres
et aujourd'hui dans un monde où les
mouvements de population sont inexorable
ils nous donnent l'exemple
il nous montre grâce à leur ouverture
grâce à leur volonté des changes que
c'est en allant vers les autres avec un
esprit de respect et de soleil de
solidarité que l'on pourra survivre
il ya quelques temps s'est tenue à
brasilia
l'assemblée internationale des peuples
autochtones
je pense que peu de gens ont internet
entendu parler de cette conférence
200 représentants indigènes du monde
entier se sont réunis pour nous lancer
un appel
un message d'unité et de mobilisation
face aux dangers qu'encourt notre
planète
j'aimerais vous proposer quelque chose
on va essayer de faire ça on va essayer
de leur envoyer un message à notre tour
je vais vous demander quelque chose d'un
peu différent si vous voulez bien me
rejoindre sur scène
nous allons former une chaîne pour leur
montrer que nous aussi nous pouvons être
unie et que nous les respectons si vous
voulez bien venir avec moi cette image
fera le tour du monde et ils la verront
un jour ou l'autre
venez venez n'ayez pas peur c'est pas la
peine d'appart heroes bout du monde pour
faire des rencontres
voilà merci monte monte au matin
venez venez n'hésitez pas par là ils
vont passer derrière nous la défaite de
la place voilà voilà
allez-y venez en a qui peuvent rester
dans la salle il n'y a pas de problème
vous n'êtes pas obligés quand même
qu'ils viennent tous assez incroyable
merci merci à vous merci à vous merci à
vous merci à vous merci pour eux merci
de penser à eux essentielle
n'ayez pas peur des autres il est pas
peur des autres merci merci beaucoup
le but